hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video wir machen heute
den zweiten part von wir reagieren auf
rebecca ringst frauen video zusammen mit
sp habe ich euch ja versprochen bei den
ersten paar doch nicht gesehen habt
checkten auf jeden fall vorher ab der
kam nämlich schon online auf diesem
kanal bsc kam auch schon im video dann
kommt auch heute das zweite lag das auch
am ende weil wir starten jetzt praktisch
mitten drin weil das video sonst viel zu
lang ging ich wünsche euch viel spaß
dabei und genießt es wenn ich das für
euch machen soll
an der ich bin echt gespannt wie das
aufgeben wird euch glauben sie wirklich
daran so ich habe oder die die gemeinde
die fans oder die wollen immer nur das
die bank geleitet
können wir die einzige medium fröhlich
ist richtig unbeholfen ich glaube die
ganzen anderen meerjungfrauen und die
ganzen anderen menschen die sich
meldungen von christin martens in diesen
glaube ich nicht so treffer zählte ja
und gibt ja viele davon ja die merken
frauen sehen das ganz große oder große
community gut müssen wir jetzt sehen wie
die sich hier irgendwie die haare ums
leben
jetzt geht es glaube ich immer oh ja
okay jetzt bin ich mal gespannt folgt
die eröffnung ist ja ich bin angekommen
hat hier schon eine flasche an
ich bin gerade ganz kurz in einem
anderen ok warte man das erste was ich
mich frage was denken diese person dahin
stell dir vor du sitzt in diesem
restaurant das jetzt einfach so ein
mädel was aussieht wie 25 dort mit einer
kamera in der hand unsere märchen von
schloss das komplett verrückt ich
bedenken einer in welche mutter wenn ich
hier gelandet das zur geige ja und ich
frage mich auch wie so familienfeiern
oder wedding aussehen sollte kommt
irgendwo eine entfernte tantal so hey
rebecca was machst du nicht noch mal hat
hier schon meine klasse an
ich verkaufe drogen keine ahnung wie das
funktionieren sollte ich habe so viel
auftrieb mit dem ding dieser platte hier
aber er ist richtig geschafft also ist
hätte ich echt nicht gedacht aber muss
schon sagen auch der aufruf schon
komischerweise schwer
ich kann mir auch nicht einfach man muss
aber sieht wirklich schön aus hast du
das schöne meerjungfrauen flosse aber im
ernst man muss ja noch was dazwischen
grätschen
sorry aber ich weiß nicht ob jetzt einer
von euch an den puls der stadt ja nicht
so an das ist ne ganze weile 27 jährige
noch 26 jährige mitnehmen lassen
hier bin ich einigermaßen gestört und
hier kann ich rumprobieren ohne gleich
heute zu vergleichen
[Musik]
heute leben würde dieses extreme weise
dahinter so tremonti ist so text images
aus dem jahr 2012 aber irgendwoher
gerade die kamera
das frage ich mich auch aber ganz im
ernst ich meine das sieht doch es sieht
nicht nach dem deutschen hotel aus oder
die türkei meine theorie ist rebecca
will bucht sich irgendwelche kleinen
hotels irgendwo der wey und nimmt da
ihre videos auch selbst den urlaub von
der steuer ab kommt weiß ich sagt ja
muss einfach sein da für diese settings
auch geil ich habe meinen tag unter
wasser im pool schwimmen also doch gar
nicht unter meist trocken
du bist dort trainieren ja dann probier
soll jetzt mit einer flosse ich wollte
ich mir das zu mir natürlich probiert
treiber mit der flosse sicher dass ich
da vorher nicht drauf gekommen
absolut um von deren geblieben
das glaube ich nicht so richtig meinst
du dir redet sich so ein dass es so
normales menschliches verhalten ist wenn
du das nicht kannst du dieses wurde
diese leute so tun als wenn sie ein
pferd hätten aber haben gar keinen
fernseher also wohl so andere menschen
so pferde spielen niveau die sonnen
stopps machst du okay man ja irgendwie
hobby hosting oder soja ist ein
steckenpferd das erinnert mich daran
ich fühle mich so schnell wo jetzt die
ja was geht da fünf filme in welchem
hotel bist du bist hier fucking
meerjungfrauen convention das sind 66
maine freundes besser hinbekommen als
sie mit diesem 67 jahre alt und kriegen
es besser hin
ja wir haben auch keine posse dann ja
sie hat ja so gesagt als hätten diese
flossen einfach sechs andere mengen von
dieser tools ein meter tief ich würde
sonst untergehen
ja aber der tag also ich weiß nicht ob
bäckerin jetzt so eine kann ich ich weiß
es nicht also wir haben auch jetzt nicht
persönlich große es ging hier wegbringen
wollen eben groß bist also aber ich kann
mir vorstellen dass dieser jemand ist
die so viel drinnen schild weist nicht
so viel rauskommt berührung mit der
natur ist wahrscheinlich wenn sie
wirklich war absaufen
ich mag eine klasse tiefer sorge
[Musik]
da gibt es doch bestimmt jetzt auch so
fetisch leute die das gut finden oder
ich traue mich noch nicht so ganz keine
ahnung irgendwie ist die flasche
jägermeister gestimmt doch noch irgendwo
mal die wunsch winkt die denn ein also
der titel lautet einen tag im pool
schwimmen ja also 40
[Musik]
ich vergesse ich nicht also ich komme
hin zur aufklärung also klar das ist
natürlich content für jüngere auch für
deutlich längere aber da guckt doch
lieber im fernsehen irgendwie sowas wie
die sesamstraße oder soja oder schaut
irgendwie so ein weißes rauschen becky
und körperkontrolle funktioniert
sie standen
ganz stark
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen im live scoring holz
compilation ja gibts sowas bitte
bestimmt und her wir wollen auch glaube
ich jetzt nicht danach suchen lieber
nicht aber wahrscheinlich gibt es auch
und jetzt mal ohne jetzt irgendwie das
auf den arm zu nehmen wie fandest du es
ihre meerjungfrauen schwimmen bewerbung
ja ich also ich fand es halt doof dass
ich nicht so gut gemacht hat wie die
anderen meerjungfrauen in dem pool
stimmt ja das habe ich auch gedacht also
ich meine so props dafür dass das
probiert rebecca aber man wenn ihr alle
anderen meldungen von besser sind dann
zu dann musst du einfach den
meerjungfrauen game einfach nochmal
abschleppen muss einfach eine schippe
drauf legen sonst geht das nicht weiter
durch das war's jetzt eigentlich auch
schon den zweiten part von ihr bei es
glaubten kanal eine sache die ich dir
noch ganz schön zeigen wollte die ich
letztens schon mal kurz gesehen habe das
war es mit dem video werfen natürlich
jetzt hat euch gefallen und checkt auf
jeden fall den zweiten part ab jetzt
einen kanal das war's haut rein